mr. Schiller congratulations thank you
how did you like the price lemony oh I
loved it I think it's great it was such
a wonderful moment not only for me but
I've learned all the others I'd like to
see recognition and given to scientists
I love the music
you predicted the crash in house prices
in the US and what's sweeping right now
oh I hate to say these thing to then I'm
a foreigner on it's none of my business
but you asked me right it is well as you
know I hate to deflate I hate to deflate
people's expectations either you know I
feel like that's a down this is a great
evening why don't I just say they're
just gonna go up and up for it but it's
not but it's not it's just like the
evening I just went through it's great
for now that reality will come later
well I actually I think it's hard to
predict these prices it's like that's
what G and Pharma one of the other
laureates is saying he would say it's
impossible so I have to one that I don't
have any really strong ability because
you don't agree but let's leave that
again I'm I could work and write some
papers on this and think about it but my
suspicion is that what's going on is in
Sweden is like what's going on in a lot
of countries around the world now and
that is a bubble but it's not a rapid
it's a so we go and we look first that's
that's the big question
okay would you buy property in
CDL stopping today honestly well if I
were starting a family here and I wanted
the home I might do that
yeah that for a long time yeah if I I
wanted to settle down here today be very
might want to sell it to you let's say
five years we don't know they're four or
five years okay two years ago I I can
think of better investments it's so you
know real estate is generally
historically not a good investment even
if it weren't highly priced so the price
of Swedish real estate is more than
doubled in real terms since the mid-90s
so it's gone up a lot and will not
continue forever
well probably now it's probably being
driven by the expert above all is but
people think that home prices are going
to go
so they make it happen the the thing
about prices long-term assets is that
there's a lot of range over they could
be at a number of different levels it's
just what people think is right for the
now your wife is a psychologist in what
way has she affected your research in
your conclusions well I think it's
pretty fundamental economics economists
rarely quote psychologists though
there's a new breed of economist that's
starting to do that but it's this I
think in any department any division of
the university there's sort of an esprit
de corps that evolved and economists
like to think of people as rational and
very intelligent calculating it's kind
of a spoiler to come in and quote
psychologist but I do
I started do it with my wife's urgent
mr. Schiller I hope for you and your
wife will get a great evening tonight
thank you so much
you